as impeachment inquiry hearings against
Donald Trump continue on Capitol Hill
the new star witness is Marie
Jovanovic and she is a former US
ambassador to Ukraine who was removed
from her post six months ago now Donald
Trump definitely does not hold her in
high esteem that's what he actually
tweeted during her testimony everywhere
Marie of a novice went turned bad she
started off in Somalia how did that go
then fast forward to Ukraine with a new
ukrainian president spoke unfavorably
about her in my second phone call with
him it is a u.s. president's absolute
right to appoint ambassadors now she
testified that she was not part of the
Biden family scandal regarding natural
gas in Ukraine and furthermore she was
not part of any effort to leak
information from Ukraine during the 2016
elections furthermore she testifies that
Donald Trump is intimidating her and
that he's responsible for all the
wrongdoing and so is Vladimir Putin well
I mean President Putin must have been
aware that there were concerns in the
u.s. about Russian meddling in the 2016
elections and what the potential was for
Russian meddling in the future so you
know classic for an intelligence officer
to try to throw off the scent and you
know create an alternative narrative
that maybe might get picked up and get
some credence yes fitting in the name of
the Russian president is what you do if
you want a catchy headline and the media
is keeping up the hype the calm before
the impeachment storm Washington's
bracing for a blockbuster day Washington
on edge all day for this second day of
impeachment hearings it was a historic
day on Capitol Hill with the first
public impeachment hearing of President
Trump tonight history on the hill as
House Democrats make their case against
President Trump and attempts to remove
the President of the United States from
office now you would think that that
would be front headline news but is the
US public really interested not too much
13 million Americans watched the first
round of testimony according to the
Nielsen ratings now that's one in 20
certainly sounds like a lot but compared
- when former FBI director James Comey
got up to testify about how he was fired
by Donald Trump 20 million Americans
watched that that's roughly the same
number as tuned in when Brett Kavanaugh
was being confirmed as a Supreme Court
justice
amid sexual assault allegations you
would expect Americans to be glued to
their TV screens now there's an actual
impeachment inquiry open after all
articles of impeachment could be drawn
up the Senate could be faced with the
choice of whether or not to convene an
impeachment trial mistakes are
significantly higher but the American
public seems far less interested I
wonder how many Americans know or even
care about the key witnesses you've
never heard of ambassador Jovanovic no
have you ever heard of George Kent are
you watching the Trump impeachment
inquiry hearings on TV does it interest
you at all
why do you think fewer Americans are
tuning in to watch the impeachment
hearings because it's to Fugazi
yeah hashtag great it's fake yeah I mean
like two three years and she's coming to
power I think like there's the one bar
after another and like it's going on and
nothing is happening actually getting
done the Brett Kavanaugh hearing was
more so like you know sensitive to the
public and this one's just everybody's
either this or there so yes it seems
that the Donald Trump is a bad guy show
has been airing from Capitol Hill for a
few seasons already but Americans are
now yawning and saying haven't we seen
this episode before caleb Maupin RT new
york
you